in this video we're going to think about
how fractions can be used to represent
things in the real world so here we're
told that on the Sharks dive team there
are three divers in third grade there
are eight total divers on the team what
fraction of sharks dive team is in third
grade so pause this video and see if you
can figure that out alright so first of
all they tell us there are eight total
divers on the team so maybe I'll
represent each diver with a little
circle like this I'll try to make it
look kinda like a diver so that's not
quite a circle but you get the idea it
looks like something kind of diving down
so one two three four five six seven and
eight now if we were to talk about just
one diver here just like that
that would be one out of the eight or we
would often call that 1/8 so eight with
an H at the end that is 1/8 right over
there or I could represent it like this
I could say this is an eighth and eighth
or I could say that this is equal to 1/8
this is one of the eight members of our
dive team now they tell us that there
are three divers in third grade what
fraction of sharks dive team is in third
grade so that is let's say it's these
three so there's three out of the eight
so if you wanted to represent that as a
fraction you could represent it as 3/8
like this or you could represent it as
if you wanted to write it out as a word
three instead of having it three over
eight you could write 3/8 like that if
you're doing this one kind of kind of
there'd be some choices out there where
you'd pick one of the correct choice but
you could represent the fraction of
sharks dive team that is in third grade
either as three over eight three eighths
or
3 and then spell out the word eighths
let's do another example here we are
told
yuuma divided his clay
his clay into four equal parts
he made clay animals out of the through
out of three of the parts what fraction
of the clay did Yuma use to make clay
animals once again pause this video and
think about it alright so let's just
imagine that this is his clay initially
and he divides it into four equal parts
and so let's say he divides it like this
and let's say that I have divided into
four equal parts that these all have the
exact amount of clay and it's hand drawn
so it's not going to be perfect the way
I drew it but let's just assume they all
have the exact same amount of clay now
it says that he made clay animals out of
three of the parts so maybe this part
right over here he was able to make a
clay animal out of this part right over
here he made a clay animal out of and
then that part right over there he made
a clay animal out of so what fraction of
the clay did he use to make clay animals
so what would you call each of the equal
parts so if I were to just focus on that
right over there you would call that
fourth fourth you could also represent
it as one fourth like that or you could
represent it as one fourth that's if you
were to just circle one of these equal
parts that one or that one or that one
or that one now if you're talking about
all of his clay what are you talking
about well you could view it as 4/4 4/4
or four over four this would also be
read 4/4 that would be referring to all
one two three four of his clay now if
you wanted to say what fraction of the
play did you may use to make clay
animals we can see that three of the
fourths were used to clay to make clay
animals so to answer that question we
would say three of the fourths so three
fourths
were used to make clay animals you can
also express that as a fraction you
could also write that as three fourths
like this you would read these the same
three fourths or three fourths three out
of the four equal sections of clay were
used to make the clay
animals